Avengers: Endgame gave fans everything they
were hoping for.
Well, almost everything.
To the surprise of many, Marvel decided to
do away with a time-honored tradition and
didn't include any mid or post-credits scenes
in Endgame.
Here are the reasons why.
Spoilers ahead!
As you're no doubt aware, a Spider-Man: Homecoming
sequel is right around the corner.
"So nice to finally meet you, Spider-Man."
Marvel president Kevin Feige has confirmed
that Spider-Man: Far From Home takes place
shortly after the events of Avengers: Endgame.
Producer Amy Pascal went one step further,
revealing that the highly anticipated Spidey
sequel is kicking off just minutes after the
fourth Avengers flick.
Seeing as Spider-Man: Far From Home is officially
the end of Phase 3, it sounds like Marvel
is saving a huge Phase 4 post-credit reveal
for that movie.
As Feige told ComicBook.com:
"There's a tremendous amount of potential
and a tremendous amount of additional characters
and storylines and groups of characters that
we're going to keep playing with."
If we're lucky, we'll get our first proper
glimpse at these new characters during the
closing credits for Spider-Man: Far From Home.
Endgame is shaping up to be the end of an
era, and the death of more than one original
Avenger makes it the heaviest Marvel movie
to date.
The studio clearly wanted viewers to take
in the three-hour movie before they began
looking forward to what's coming next.
As The Verge's Chaim Gartenberg wrote:
"With Endgame, it's time to pay the check
and end the story instead of endlessly escalating
and teasing the next thing."
While there was no post-credits scene to speak
of, Marvel didn't leave us totally hanging.
Fans who were willing to sit through the lengthy
credits were rewarded with a little surprise:
a huge Marvel logo and a clanking sound.
[clang, clang, clang, clang]
Sure, this probably left a lot of viewers
scratching their heads, but fans who have
been with the MCU from the very beginning
quickly recognized the sound.
[clang, clang, clang, clang]
As if to reinforce the idea that every film
we'd seen was building up to this film, Marvel
decided to make the final moment in the credits
a nod to the Marvel movie that started it
all: 2008's Iron Man.
It's the sound of Tony Stark cobbling together
his Iron Man shell from the first Iron Man.
While Endgame was clearly something of a swansong
for some of the original Avengers, the man
of the hour was Tony Stark.
He started it all in that cave, and he ended
it when he snapped Thanos and his army out
of existence.
There's been plenty of news regarding the
future of the Marvel Cinematic Universe post-Phase
3, with Marvel president Kevin Feige having
discussed a number of projects that the studio
currently has in the pipeline.
Feige has suggested the Eternals will play
a big role in the plot going forward.
He's also revealed that an appearance from
Ms. Marvel - otherwise known as Pakistani
American teen Kamala Khan - is a distinct
possibility in the near future.
Feige told the BBC,
"[The character is] definitely sort of in
the works."
The producer has been purposefully vague as
far as details are concerned, and for very
good reason: The fact of the matter is, Phase
4 is still very much up in the air.
With that in mind, creating a post-credits
scene for Avengers: Endgame would've been
especially tricky.
Guess we'll just have to wait and see what
the future has in store,.
As a wise man once said:
"Sometimes patience is the key to victory.
Sometimes it leads to very little."
That's… very true.
As for what Phase 4 has in store, guess we'll
just have to patiently wait until Spider-Man:
Far From Home hits theaters on July 5th, 2019.
"You don't want any part of this!"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Avengers:
Endgame are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.